[Musique]
au son des tambours sacrés des dizaines
de pèlerins quitte le lazaret de la
grande chaloupe pour marcher vers la mer
et rendre hommage aux travailleurs
engagés qui ont peuplé lille après
l'abolition de l'esclavagé en 1848
c'est un droit un devoir de mémoire de
nos ancêtres mais surtout pour que nous
puissions transmettent les informations
les données nécessaires à nos enfants au
public qui sont là qui viennent qui
habite à la réunion qui connaissent pas
forcément leur histoire et le site d'el
azhar et se porte bien effectivement
pour mieux appréhender cette histoire le
lazaret de la grande chaloupe était le
principal lieu de quarantaine pour s'est
engagée originaires pour la plupart
d'inde d'afrique et de chine et bien eu
des engagés chinois qui sont arrivés à
partir de 1843 et cette journée de
commémoration
elle est pour tous les travailleurs
engagés qu'ils soient chinois ou
d'origine chinoise de shenzhen et au
delà tout ça c'est aussi devenu une
journée de mémoire de symboles de notre
histoire peut-être un peu un peu un peu
négative mais qui a malheureusement
effet partie de haddada des socles de la
construction aujourd'hui les prières et
les offrandes sont fait symboliquement
face à la mer un hommage spirituel rendu
par les différentes associations
cultuelles président il ya des prières
qui ont été qu'ils ont été
dit pour des
pour des différentes divinités un ganesh
on commence toujours par le dieu ganesh
ensuite shiva et vit chez nous parce que
selon notre selon la do is mme lorsque
une personne décède on dit qu'il va
retrouver soi shiva soit vishnou donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a honoré ses deux
divinités là on a rendu hommage à ses
deux divinités pour pouvoir bien entendu
qui pour qu'il veille sur nos ancêtres
et pour que nos ancêtres eux-mêmes
veille sur nous inscrit au titre des
monuments historiques
les vestiges des lazaret 1 et 2 marque
l'histoire du peuplement de l'île un
site hautement symbolique que le conseil
départemental restaure et valorise pour
comprendre l'histoire de l'engagisme à
la ring
[Musique]